thank you the category Best Supporting
Actor might be a little misleading in
any role of every size each actor
supports every other actor in the cast
through the dynamic characters they
portrayed five actors each nominated for
the first time gave their strength and
spirit to their fellow actors and gifted
us with striking performances for Best
Actor in a supporting role the nominees
are James Cromwell in babe
Edie Harris in Apollo 13
Brad Pitt in twelve-month ease
Tim Roth and Rob Roy
Kevin Spacey in the usual suspects
and the Oscar is presented to Kevin
Spacey and the usual suspects
well whoever Keyser söze is I can tell
you he's going to get gloriously drunk
tonight and that's a question that I'm
often asked who is Keyser söze and I've
always been very cryptic about my answer
but tonight I'm going to tell you who
Keyser söze is for me the person who
pulls the strings the person who
manipulates who hovers over us who gives
us life and breath for me
Keyser Soze is Bryan Singer the director
of this film and I thank him for his
friendship and for giving me an
extraordinary part and for making me a
better actor than I ever thought I could
be I have dreamed of a moment like this
my whole life
I thank my manager Joann my agent Bryan
Gersh and on a personal note to my
mother
I am so proud that you can be here
tonight thank you so much
thank you so much mom for driving me to
those acting classes on Ventura
Boulevard when I was 16 I told you they
would pay off and here's the pudding
thank you